nous sommes avec jérôme marty médecin
généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre et
membre du collectif sos retraite jérôme
marty bonsoir soir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france nouvelle
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui pour
les médecins libéraux également vous
voulez maintenir la pression
mais bien sûr on est engagé dans un
combat qui va être un combat long mais
c'est un combat primordial parce que
cette réforme est extrêmement dangereuse
pour l'ensemble nos professions du soin
elle est dangereuse pour les médecins
mais elle est dangereuse pour l'ensemble
des paramédicaux et donc qu'elle est
dangereuse pour les français parce
qu'elle va entraîner une casse très
importante dans la profession et donc on
va se dire on est en droit de se
demander qui va vous soigner demain
très concrètement qu'est ce qui va se
passer si cette réforme de retraites et
mise en place qu'est ce qui va se passer
pour un médecin généraliste qui s'est
installé deux exemples très simple pour
les paramédicaux c'est la même
problématique que pour les avocats c'est
à dire que leurs cotisations vont passer
de 14 à 28 % et ce sont des professions
que les tarifs qui sont comme pour les
médecins au plus bas de la moyenne
européenne ils ne pourront pas faire
face à ses charges et donc des centaines
et des centaines de cabinets vont fermer
et pour les médecins ce sont les
pensions qui vont diminuer de 30 à 34 %
donc ça veut dire que un tiers des 2
dudu du bénéfice fait d'un tiers un
tiers de la manne économique des
retraites va diminuer va diminuer et ça
on ne pourra pas y faire face non plus
ça va baisser l'attractivité de nos
professions qui dit baisse
d'attractivité dit que moins de médecins
- s'installer donc plus déserts médicaux
et c'est ainsi que l'hôpital va très mal
on sait que les urgences vont très mal
on sait que la médecine de ville va très
mal fin bref on se demande s'il ya un
endroit dans le soin qui ne va pas mal
suite à la gestion de l'état et ce même
état prétend pouvoir gérer nos retraites
mais nous nous avons la faiblesse de lui
dire non nous ne vous croyons pas parce
que nous ne pouvons pas signer un
contrat qui est un contrat léonin
puisque vous nous dites vous vous vous
devez vous amenez vos réserves et l'état
lui ne nous amène que de la baisse donc
son contrat léonin
les avocats vont être reçus demain
demain soir à matignon
les médecins est ce que vous êtes en
contact avec le gouvernement il ya une
réunion de prévue prochainement
il ya des réunions qui sont faites avec
un à deux syndicats qui à mon avis se
trompent énormément parce que ils font
confiance encore à cette réforme alors
que vous l'avez vue là la grande
majorité des professionnels libéraux
quels qu'ils soient n'ont pas confiance
parce que encore une fois cette réforme
représente un réel danger il faut savoir
que nos professions sont des professeurs
aujourd'hui fragilisée tous les patients
de france le vivent et on ne peut pas se
permettre d'aller vers une réforme qui
risque de fragiliser un peu plus
aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'elle est gérée la
retraite des médecins libéraux et des
professions libérales paramédical
comment est-ce que j'ai jamais un des
avocats
nous avons comme les avocats nous avons
des caisses qui sont des caisses
autonomes c'est à dire que normalement
nous ne sommes pas concernés par cette
réforme cette réforme concerne le régime
général et ce régime général nous en
avons été exclus à ça quand on l'a mis
en place en 45
donc nous avons mis en place nous des
caisses autonomes qui sont la solidarité
professionnelle où chaque médecin
cotisent pour les médecins les
infirmières cotisent pour les
infirmières etc etc
nous les avons à gérer en bon père de
famille et nous avons su faire face aux
erreurs politiques qui ont amené la
chute démographique en acceptant de
cotiser plus et de recevoir moins pour
constituer des réserves
ces réserves en totalité il faut savoir
que ça représente quand même 130
milliards pour l'ensemble des
populations donc des populations idéal
donc on est en face de quoi on est en
face d'un hold up en col blanc
c'est votre argent videmment qu'ils
videront veut récupérer épreuve année
d'ailleurs que l'état nous dit les
réserves vont servir à organiser la
transition vers le nouveau système mais
c'est pas ça qu'elles servent les
réserves les réserves elles servent à
faire face au trou démographique
elles servent à payer des pensions elles
ne servent pas à payer des cotisations
va pas payer des cotisations et des
cotisations alors on sait bien que ce
gouvernement une façon très crue âge de
gérer puisque là les députés discutent
d'une réforme dont ils n'ont ni les
tenants ni les aboutissants matière
financière ces caméras ordinaire et
cette idée d'une réforme plus juste plus
solidaire
r défendue par le gouvernement vous en
pensez quoi je pense que c'est du tout
peau passez moi le mot elle n'est ni
juste ni solidaire pas juste parce que
elle représente un réel danger de
fermeture pour nos cabinets parce que la
paire et notre pérennité économique et
mise en danger et elle n'est absolument
pas jenny solidaire ni sage nous nous
sommes solidaires nous abondons des
caisses qui sont déficitaires et nous ne
comptons pas un rond à l'état pains et
là on veut nous on veut nous faire
croire que régime universel va être
solidaire il va pas être solidaire
ça va être un régime à points dont les
points vont être définies par le
parlement et ces points vont varier en
fonction de l'état économique du pays et
force est de constater que depuis 30 ans
notre pays va mal sur le plan économique
donc on a du souci à se faire
le débat parlementaire a débuté
aujourd'hui on l'a vu ils risquent
d'être houleux est ce que vous craignez
en entre le passage en force du
gouvernement
il devrait offrir un peu le cren ça
c'est certain mais à mon avis ça serait
la dernière chose à faire on a des
élections municipales qui soit
extrêmement proches
immédiatement derrière il ya les
élections présidentielles le temps passe
très vite vouloir imposer cette réforme
à des gens qui voient quatre fois la
population française chaque année qu'un
taux de confiance entre 84 80 et 90 % et
donc une réelle influence de conseil sur
les gens ça serait à mon avis prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de risques alors il ya
eu des milliers d'amendements notamment
de la part de la france insoumise
pour vous c'est une bonne tactique
tactique dangereuse comment est ce que
vous le percevez tremblay parlementaire
quoique j'ai entendu le gouvernement
dira que c'était pas démocratique au
contraire je crois que c'est quelque
chose de très démocratique ça ouvre à la
discussion
force est de constater qu'il n'y a eu
aucune discussion
vous avez que vous avez ville très
concrètement les médias est mauvaise a
prévu dialogue il ya eu des réunions
avec des explications avait des paper
board et les powerpoint ou leurs
représentants du gouvernement monsieur
delevoye dont on sait comment dans
quelles conditions il est parti puis
monsieur pitre avait ce qui faisait
venaient présenter leurs réformes et
n'écoutez pas n'écoutez pas ce qu'on
leur disait épreuve années que les gens
qui dirigent nos caisses autonomes ont
été proprement foutu dehors de ces
discussions à la deuxième réunion parce
qu'il contredisait le gouvernement voilà
comment le gouvernement conçoit le
dialogue
vous n'avez pas été écoutés c'est ça
aujourd'hui ce que vous reprochez au
gouvernement oui mais sur du coup quelle
suite
quelle action vous vous avez prévu à
l'avenir justement pour toujours lutter
contre ces mails déjà il souhaite
retraite grossistes mouvement qui est un
mouvement pluriprofessionnelle vous le
savez de paramédicaux des métiers du
chiffre de métiers du transport de
métiers de la justice et de la santé
de nouveaux syndicats se sont agrégés il
y à une union qui se crée donc on va
effectivement continuer à faire des
actions mobilisation dans les rues arrêt
et sans doute de de tout ce qui est
administratif dans nos professions comme
ça se passe à l'hôpital actuellement
et puis sans doute d'autres d'autres
actions on part pour un come back est un
combat long merci beaucoup jérôme marty
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre et
membre du collectif sos retraite merci à
vous